Hellooooooooo!!
Everybodyyy!
Welcome back to finding paradise so glad you made it. We've been playing for hours. Oh my god
Apparently the game is like five and a half hours, so we might have some hey, dude. I just realized
Look at this moon. I will I'm moonwalking. I'm moonwalking in this game
Now if you're not filled in on the story. Don't worry
I will explain it all to you, so please keep watching. Please keep what damn it, and he might be Miss Lilly's place
I'm joking all the support on this has been amazing
Okay, well the story took a strange turn
Last episode there's something going on with dr. Watts alright the we don't know what he's doing, but he's doing something
There's some other
alternative
Adjustments to this now. I don't remember
What I was supposed to do
Do you hear me ever
I'm coming back in are you still in there? Are you still there?
patients near links to something like
Okay
Oh my god, thank you
Hey, I think I saw your Patna smashing distant space me
Spasming best sub word is something wrong of course net we got this down. Where we I'm going back in there now
Okay, I'm getting on you. I might as well just go
Nothing holding me back now
It's very real, what do you guys think leave a comment?
Here they are again, they're so cute what I don't like this music done
Where is she
Ever
Is it ever or Eva
In Savini was a yabba
Not that you care. It's probably best not to provoke anything before figuring out what's going on? I?
Should find Eva first ibanez Eva. Ha don't need your help get out of here. Where is she?
Nani
The fuck she's in the post-office thing of course, but you didn't think of that
This is strange very strange, huh?
The link to his timeline over well got unlocked
Even if Eva's not there anymore it'd be easier to look for her from there
Yeah, why not?
I
Don't think she's here she's clearly not here what the heck Eridu carries this
These are all the mementos and all the links
We never seen this before
She's not here though Eva are you here?
We became a flying sperm congratulations everyone every memory of Colleen that we pierced together so far
She's gotta be in one of them I
Actually have to find her oh
Not detected
Why could she be
The vortex of the enemy that's been bouncing us around guess is near the memory we left off a
So I didn't read it not detected. What is happening to this game. It's so different now. Yeah, not here either
She's not gonna be in anywhere
Either she's here or not here
She's missing dagnabbit. How can she be in the machine, but nowhere in the memories unless she's here here
system narrow down Eva's most recent position
Nanny well, duh frickin Bermuda Triangle
Guess it's back to the crime scene
Something's up something's definitely up
System load up all available recordings from here
This video what is this?
To the moon tube
I'm heading out get ready get the forms ready get the forms ready for a filling wait what?
Alright fast forward come on. Where is she where is she?
Freaking Court corn cobs how can this one memory link be so hard to find?
That idiot sure is taking his sweet time
9:36 p.m.. Wait a minute. Wait a minute what she was to here
Fast forward yes, yes, yes few minutes later
Are you on a computer?
So we don't know what happened in between good. Could you run this record search and fan check for any aviation accidents? I?
Just want to rule out the possibility of something out
Okay alright a few a few minutes later two minutes later
And she's got she's got there. She Neil can you hear me?
Hello, are you there?
Neil if you can hear me
Listen I don't think she's real. She's
She's all in his head and something strange is happening
Hello, say something I'm giving up on you
Goddamn this system glitched out. This is hella crazy
Whoa the tree just hey
Hey, but a bingo what does happen oh?
Well we've never seen this before
What is this whoa oh
Oh that oh. Oh you oh
I'm scared for real what the heck?
What you did it team? Oh?
My god that was freaky as hell
What dammit visit him in the frickin genre beta that set up birth. Oh my god
This game went from zero to 100. What do you want love?
We can't leave this is our job calling signup safer has to be here the changes mom
Belong here
Fine you want to play hardball, let's play freakin hit, babe
Again a few trip are we gonna fight? We're gonna fight. Please fight. That's right. Are you gonna be nice now?
You may have lost you have may have they host subconsciousness, but I'm still the admin of this world
Mother but I never thought I'd have to use this, but you leave me no choice
It's 10:00 to show you my true power oh
This gesture control interface was a terrible idea
Yeah, Oh
His transfer man uh
Salamone
Kauai this name
Well the minecraft armor the golden minecraft armor the strongest armor of all
Yay
Don't forget to helmet
Wow incredible
This is so ridiculous
This is what happened whenever isn't around yeah
Eva Jesus
If you think I'm going to show mercy you've been sadly mistaken
Give up now and I make us ha ha ha
old shoes she had the last momento
Am she strong she took it back
Please leave
Oh
Dad maybe
That's why
this is so not what I built that backdoor for I
Guess even my code needs testing before practical use
And what the heck happened to Eva I need to get to the bottom of this oh
Now we're running the book I
Can't really she was here wasn't she when something happen
What do I do?
Maybe you can go in here now any instance of Kahlan should get me back to the overworld
So we're stuck here
Okay
All right, we're back here system narrow it down positions of rogue mental activity
What
She's split up everywhere where to even begin
I'll get to that when things aren't batch. Okay. We just have to look for her everywhere
This is so strange
She's here same way I find her dagnabbit system disabled interactivity
for all non operators including Colin I
Find that beer and I'll put her to justice
we're
Way where is she dammit I click that by accident where?
Should I go back. I'll just go back
So clicking calling just takes us back, but we have to find her somewhere shouldn't it be a no Mendte
the painting that is clicking on every I
Don't know oh oh
Good good try, but I sure don't recall the person looking like that you look a little distorted by the way oh
my god
Try scrilla Singh in there and look in the Sun
What
What that
But is this place
Laura tava know
What wait a minute this? This is my unfinished interface? How are you even here?
And where is Eva?
Orosco, I'll tell her you were going to remove me from Connors memories ah
We weren't necessarily gonna
To do your job house or not you said yourself that you'd start with me, then right you're running out
We only said that because we didn't know you can hear us ha ha ha
Wait wait that came out wrong
But listen you need to believe me. I'm on the patient's side not the contract this this just is a misunderstanding
Maria do what's best for Carling and you can work with us to make it happen?
Hmm that does sound in person, but the ribbon as if that were the clothes
But xalapa loves her well, that's no
Ow
Access to its current memory tonight commencing first booty hey wait I'm the admin, ah shit
Damn it did my own system. Just elope with my patients freaking imaginary friend
Okay, let's try another one
So she'll be hiding inside something
This is the memory of him and his son oh, and we did see a shadow over here over there on this side that
Was you walking by there wasn't it, that's how I
Think I just twisted my voke of course that's none of your business anymore
It's the same thing just gonna happen over and over this again
Hey look over there oh
I
Can't believe that worked I
Mean it didn't work. But oh sorry. I hit space by accident. Why don't you just give up and leave us alone?
So now calling signed the contract, but it did it out of desperation
But I only did it and I didn't understand the consequences for the dust now
Listen I don't know what you take us for but we're here to help him I mean
I don't know exactly how yet, but at least give us a chance
Just tell me where eva is and I'll give us the memory link so we can finish the chat
your car look
to tell you the truth, I don't actually nourishes and
as for the memory lunch
I'm gonna bitch slap it out of here
Whoa
Okay
Girl half the girl formal I
Said
Fight alright so I move and shoot
That what's your choice, but that's not big I can't even leave a mark on you whoa?
Uh-oh I
Can't block that
What that mean?
What was I supposed to do there? There was no chance at out?
How access to current memory denied commencing first booting okay this sex
This is pretty crazy
Guess we just have no choice, but to keep
Keep doing this
This is his last day
Maybe we saw someone out here eyelashes, I found you
So how did you buy a ticket for that seat?
Motherfucker, I wasn't even here in the absent memories does it right
Then who is she and where did she come from I am so confused
Hey look that paper plane thing was totally uncool
But what did you mean when you said?
You don't know where eva is I saw the footage you were the one who locked her away
No
All I did was lock the communication channels and give her scare
I don't know where she went afterwards in fact. She disappeared soon after you returned
Disappeared as in she unplugged from the Machine plus. She's no longer here, and if you don't love her
Well, I'm gonna make sure
What is that was
Another one all right, what is it this time check?
Wait how are you even accessing my private programs like this ow son of M. That wasn't what I was asking it out
And a hadoukens and shit jump defend space
Well damn it. I can't even Sheila attacks. Oh aah
I want to beat her
Hey, I was rooting for you, I liked you a minute ago alright, what is this anymore?
The diva really unplugged from the machine, maybe I should to wait, but if I'm not here either
They might even be able to reset our progress I guess there's at least some use in keeping her busy
Alright, we have two more
This is fairly straightforward
Might as well I say oh
Wait a minute shut the matter kudasai
This this isn't the last accessible memory where we saved a
Communicative copy of Colin not quite as bright as the real thing, but sharp eats nothing at uh
So, where is she where is she I?
Don't
Right Oh
Carlene can you hear me? Oh this one in the front are your back. Yes listen. I need your head
God dammit, what the hell oh oh?
Okay
Look at that
How did she get into the code?
You lock down the one who created you
That no that's not the real Karla that's merely a partial copy of him that were created
Look we don't have a lot of time Lee if carly's wishes to be fulfilled. We need you to work village
Do you still not understand columns register? No longer some something? It's no longer something you can grant to
Katherine our it's resolved to become
What it is oh well I didn't do anything unless
Even ah
Hey, that wasn't so bad anymore, haha wait a minute oh
Sweet it's a Christmas miracle, and it is Christmas turn to the head of your stuff
Uppercut punch
Well it's about to get real guys this again
Other art let's err. That's awesome
Alright yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Okay, maybe I shouldn't okay. I can block some birds
You're shocked man come on come on. She's presently taking any damage
Come on
SDPs more dots more dots gather Gacha sure time I
Can't dodge that
This is for calm only I have the power of God and anime on my side I
nearly found that crazy all going oh, oh no I uh
Know what that one huh, I'm alive Oh
Suzie Shh oh
No
It's getting hard
Come on my head
yeah, I
am the best
gamer in the planet
Whoa ow
Rogue activity no longer detected in his memory
Finally something's working
This is a vlog : still like some hair returned to Colin's ever word yes
We got one more to go through I
Wonder if it even matters if you beat him Eva, are you here some way
She clearly did something last time oh
This memory was so sweet
we have to ruin it I
Like your face you were the chosen one you were supposed to bring balance to the Colin
Hey ha ha ha
You've been here since the beginning haven't you vocalist laughs that's suppose
You're at the kick her ass again cuz I will
Come on. You lost your age careful. Not to cut it yourself on it. That's correct the confidence for someone who just got lucky
There's still time work with this
And we'll make the best of this join us the best of this word bizarre living Carlin our marijuana
And I'll be the one method shawl of that
I'm sorry Faye
You was gone dad. Oh, I wasn't good at this. Okay way down was defend
you know I can take you on now, right ah
Geronimo
Okay dear friend
Mother
Yeah, it's not going great
No I was so close I
Have to redo it not freaking cool. Yeah, I'll just redo it I just messed up
My bad haven't had enough guess not
Leave calling along your crazy academic what's with the jumping?
Wow
Almost got her
There you go
Easy best game on the planet. Thank you very much. I want to thank my mom
I want to thank swole Ben, and I want to thank
Anyone that is watching do you like oh yeah Ava should see me now?
What up
Collin
Don't you learn how to play a game?
Like me all right think about that
External patching installation initiated what that is that you River?
Rogue mental activity dig deep this wasn't here before
Suppose I can join him with my sperm
Here we are this is the breaking point
Maybe even sout here
She must be
Vicious
Mmm
Even there you weigh hey
Where have you been I've been looking everywhere for you
Did you see Fae around here? Don't worry? I took care of her excuse me. I took care of her already
What did you do? Oh?
And sorry about the mess here. I probably should have gained it cleaned it up. You know I've been thinking that we should just leave
wait what the
Patient clearly doesn't want us here. We should respect his wishes
What are you talking about the patients don't always know what they really want. Do you of all people should know?
Wait a minute. You know oh I
Guess it's nice
You should know by now you aren't just gonna leave
They really didn't want to do any more. I really don't know what to do anymore, but they have to keep going even
If it just turns you
Okay wait hold on just a minute ah shoes
What is going on this has been so crazy well, this class sure aren't as fluffy St. Luc
Disappointment uh-oh it's boss battle time
Whoa I
Just became an actual RPG huh attack Armageddon kick wait there was shoe as an option
What can she do then ow
Well I have to try shoe
yeah, take that ah
Son of it, okay all right attack tornado punch
Yeah, yeah, yeah look angry about ah
Ah ah she's too strong you know for an imaginary character your attacks are kind of vanilla ha ha
Yeah take shoo
Ah shoot ah
Rip rudoug BrewDog he's on my site ah nevermind ow ow and out in ow
I could really use some hair
Maybe would defend one look. We don't have to do this then
I'll never give up dan look at that damage dawg
But it's not enough I don't think we could have won that one
Dagnabbit
Wait what
Don't give up. Do you well there was this one time with a long line of at the grocery store?
But here guess not
I'd rather just have to keep fighting
Guess I have to learn which attacks do more damage
I do more damage nano may
I'm not sure. What is expected of me here
I'm still not strong enough shoe great what that?
He put my shoe back
rudoug is join the party ah
alright
roadog
compliment tip nose laser nose LASIK, yeah
Hell yeah rude. Oh, ah
Son of a brute ugh, this is now question rudoug
Why drew Doug
The imaginary dog is question and ceases to exist dammit
Why Lisa why
Yes my god, this is ridiculous
Never question your dog guys
Alright we know that one does the most damage in these
Maybe we should just
like not even attack and just defend until we get ruh dog I
Don't know
Probably, that's what you have to do I
Know I'll defend now because now the dogs will come
Look at that and then we'll throw the shoe
Ruh dog returns just as planned
And then rude dog will do a rocket dog
Dan Oh was that a chemically no. He wasn't good
Then hopefully we can withstand at least two more attacks
No, no no go back
oh
Come on. Don't question true dog
I'll just defend then
Okay cool and then no lacing
Nice we can do this we can do this
Yes
Defend go row dog as much as I want to try the compliment. It doesn't seem worth it at this point we did it
Amazing I am truly the greatest aren't you glad you're watching. I know you are oh?
My
Where that was a hoot
Ah shoot Roo Doc's still up there I forgot to thank him, but why did he help me?
Shouldn't y'all made-up beings act in unison of Colin's subconsciousness
Maybe even can't I mean save ISA no way so sherry what he want so wait
It's the one widow that you tempt him with it's not no surprise that he got lost
Hey Sookie do
You mean it no what he wants, but don't know what he needs
Look you may be part of his mind, but clearly you don't speak for his entirety
could it be that you are wrong I
Mean no offense, but you aren't much more than that in complete copy of Colin back there in fact
I'm not even sure if there's a point in talking to you right now
After all you're just an authorial figment of his imagination that never even existed
Gonna hit you, but they start any different from what you're here to do
Whoa
We got all kinds of thing happening even
Hey
Sorry, I had to head out for a moment there
She's all in Cullen's head by the way. Oh, yeah, I'm intermediate
intimately familiar with that fact right now
But what were you doing you just bail out on me? Oh?
Even Oats business I was out administrating cicadas to curb call this brain activity
Not sure how his mental process could override us, but it's getting out of hand
So that wasn't a Christmas miracle after all
It took a while to work out the door such as we still need his brain functioning
Seems like it's working though the effects should be sinking in more now Oh
Not dog sport Wow just what have you been dealing with over here, don't ask oh?
She got zapped a half Batman
What the heck is there just some you cold, Roxy sent me
She said she saw issues with the Machine earlier and knew we'd be in trouble
Wrote a patch in the car while Rob was driving up early. Wow she's not
sure if
She's really not that dumb. Huh did did she say anything else about the Machine?
Aside from you doing a crappy job with the self repairs. No not like there was much time to talk
Actually, I'm still not sure I've Colin is stable enough for this to work yet. Oh
Huh, I didn't expect her to be locked down for good this soon
Did we just catch her as a pokemon. That's amazing you miss it you missed a tire tired calling out quite a bit
Well there was a it was hard fun. Yeah
But whatever he was good thing this worked my dad. We'd have time Fred
We trying I don't I do have some questions for you about this incident, though
But those can wait until the case is done
The effect of this ladies is temporary we have little time as it is
Come on. Let's move on already what we still came
Finally
This might just be the most hassle. We've ever gone through for a single memory link. Yep seems about right
Hmm, what is it? Oh? It's just something? She said earlier
Hmm the whole thing was messed up. She did she turned freaky and ghastly on YouTube. Yeah, but that's not what I meant
Nevermind, let's just get going in chat later
Do we have what's the met meant oh, then I guess this is not exactly a journal after all
Sheesh
Are they just spreading hibiscus seeds wherever they go there? We go we got one?
nice a memory link a
Memento. Oh, it's time finally for everyone's favorite 10. Oh, No
oh
There we go
And they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming and they don't stop coming I
Know exactly what I'm doing?
Look at that
Genius
Strikes again, oh my god
Let's go through Bros, Racha chess squad famous
What
Packing up interative data for a blade selection
Data Becker complete Institute - repository
What in the world is going on
That took a while weren't you right behind me, I just had to clean up some cement I'm inspecting
And we never been here before have we
Well let's go and see what we find out the vortex of all this I have a guess
Well here's another one of these
And wonder what's gonna happen? I still don't know maybe Fey is real. I mean she's got to come from somewhere
She needs a d-stick that they didn't exactly stick this everything
I'm sorry
Landing her not like I had much practice on an actual grass strip
So do you think this is case of schizophrenia
Well with that the patient usually has trouble actively distinguishing delusions from reality
But I in this case I get the feeling when he's that. He's actually well aware of it
Still can't say for certain, but I'm leaning towards some kind of defense mechanism instead
The more curious question is how she's able to materialize so vividly
You think she's still able to yes hard to say, but she shouldn't be able to interfere for now at least
This seems to be just a normal memory playback
Hmm interesting
Would you forgive me
Haven't you ever heard of the phrase stop and smell the roses?
There are flowers in Tiffany Hill tyranny
every city
They make it she can't just be in
His head I don't believe that I
Don't want to believe it
We're going a werewolf is hunting her
Hey, I was thinking it's a little windy today, maybe we should come back some other time instead
Damn you we're practically ready
Hey remember when we played catch me she came
The wind it wasn't there a moment ago
So shit's getting windy
Okay, what did you marry me?
Let's just rest here for a while
Again? You barely walked any steps.
Hey, I'm the one who has to carry this thing uphill
Oh, I just thought you'd have gotten stronger by now, that's all...
The cello got bigger too, y'know. Just come and sit here with me for a bit. Will you?
Do you remember the first time we came here
Which first time...?
The second time I or the second one I guess
The one where I tried to race you up the hill
Yeah, there was a dumb move
You sure were excited to take me up there, though
Yeah
It had been a while since I took anyone there
It's still one of my favorite places. I've always liked how it overlooked the city
It really has been a while hasn't it. I rather miss going there
So why are you hesitating?
We're mere steps away from there y'know. Why are you stopping every step along the way?
Stop kidding yourself Colin..
You're not tired and it's not the wind
We've already come so far... you know as well as I what we have to do.
What?
Sorry what
Why is it so quiet
Are they playing
Where are they? There they are
The first time we came here
That was the first time I accompanied to play the scales too, wasn't it?
Yeah... it helped
It still does actually
Well no one likes to practice scales alone
But you can never actually hear what I was playing could you?
What?
What
Aww
It's nice up here today.
It always is.
You don't have to leave anymore.
I can fly now
Wherever you go, I can go with you
You really are stubborn aren't you?
Don't you think you're getting a bit too old for me to stay?
People would laugh at you if they knew
They can laugh all they want, I don't care
You made me who I am today
I learned to fly because of you... I kept playing the cello because of you
You taught me to practice the scales
No, Colin
I can't teach you anything you don't know nor can I make you do anything you don't want
Maybe all you really wanted was for something to be there
Even if it was just someone like me
Who is she
I know it's mesmerizing here Colin
But you've been spending so much time with me, and imagining what couldn't be
Don't you think you're forgetting?
What actually is and all that could be?
Sometimes stepping in this little world we made
It's the only way to notice and appreciate all the beautiful things around you
I just don't want to be alone
Sure if I go you'll be alone at times even when you don't want to be
But that's all a part of growing up and it's all a part of life
It's what makes fleeting moments with loved ones treasured, and our moments precious
It's also what drives you to seek out what you wouldn't find if you just stayed here with me
There's a lot out there just waiting for you. I'm sorry the voice. I hate it right now
I can't promise it'll always be good, but I know you won't find all that you need living only in these pages of ours
You brought me into this world don't forget it.
And while some things are meant to stay.. some are only meant to carry you so far.
In my own way, you know I will always be there to protect you
And whatever comes if it's something we could do, then it's something you could do
What do you say Colin? Are you ready?
I'm not
I don't know
I don't think I'm ready for it to end
I don't care what you are or aren't
You were my first real friend
Hey this doesn't have to end for it
One day you might look back and realize how fast this precious life has passed you by
And on that day I'll come back once more
We'll talk like how we used to talk and you tell me about your day
No
about your life
You'll tell me about what a happy life you had
And all the nice memories you've had
I might not have such a happy life, you know
Oh... I get it now. You're such a downer, you know that?
Have a little faith in yourself Colin
Of course you will I know you will
It may take a long time and it may take a lot of work and effort
But when that day comes, I know you'll have lots of happy memories to share
Ah, it's almost time
How much have you written in that book by now? You've replaced its pages so many times, huh?
I must talk a lot, sorry about that
But now that I'm going,  perhaps you could finally spare more pages for other things
It's your book. You don't have to always write about me anymore
It's just like life right?
Same book filled with all kinds of different pages, as it should be
Take care of you yourself alright?
Hey
I still haven't said goodbye yet
You already have, Colin...
A long long time ago
What? sorry can I just finish
She never came back did she
Guess not
I wonder if she's a cause or an effect
Hm?
As in, do you think Colin's unhappy because she never came back again
If Colin only wanted to see her again I doubt he would have needed to call us
He would have needed Scott yeah, but perhaps ransom that Ian meant that she was already unhappy he was already unhappy by then
back to square one
This place is destabilizing again. We don't have much time left. Let's move we have to make do with what we had
Wait do we even know what we're doing with him yet
I've a few ideas to try but we still need to link the mementos first
Let's get back to the overworld and figure things out while we do that. all right
Uh-oh what the heck wait just a
In my own way I will always be there to protect you
Yeah, what's taking so long?
Shit uh-oh this place forgot pie there's no tank to wheat frame
Okay, let me do a quick same uh
We're gonna have to end that episode there excuse me
I've only been away a few minutes I
Was like I?
Wonder if it's actually that much left, so I looked up, and I didn't know what's gonna happen or anything
But I looked up just to be safe, and it's true
I I literally have we have like 20 minutes left, and it would be insane to stop now
Even though this episode will be super extra long which I know you of course appreciate oh
Okay, we need to connect the links
The book to the book the plane to the plane
and
The Hibiscus to the Hibiscus he doesn't have any viscous so that's not gonna work
Okay he's the only I think this is it. Yeah the Hibiscus was to key all along I
Am good at this aren't I
Maybe I probably just sold the puzzles so much quicker than everyone else, and that's why I thought the play time was different
But I'm probably just such a genius that I can't help myself
It's late alright
I'm saying overtime I
Think that's a little bit oh
My god oh my god, oh
Hell yeah
I
Just realized I shouldn't have red-faced voice in such a stupid fucking moist
Such a such an emotional moment I'm just doing this stupid voice
What is this place
Hey look at that
So I guess Fay was like his fake friend like a pretend friend. I don't know what it's called in English
Excuse me call them call them, but when you go through the procedure and live that new life
Just hold on to something from here
It's not like that for you. I won't forget about you
Damn
He's I guess he's dying
But in the blink of an eye suddenly, there's no more time, and I find myself here, just like everyone else
I just want to feel like I've done enough in this world before I go you know
That's why we are here calling. Tell us your regrets. What is it you want mr. Fix?
We only have so little time in this knife, and we'd never be able to do all that we want no matter what we do
There'd always be other things. We'd want to try other paths to take
Uh-huh
Did I spill it on your dress. Hey, just one more excuse to jump into the lagoon
You know we don't have to waste all that lemon juice
Have you ever tried riding with it
Lemon juice no why ha then prepare to be mind blown by some elementary school magic
Get this its invisible ink
invisible ink
Yep, writing appears in color only when you heat the paper up
Come on I'll show you let's write something with it
It's been a while since I written
It was Fay was like a fictional character for him
It's never too late to start again
How about a letter to her each other of course we write about this trip
It's been kind of a journey hasn't it?
And at the end of it we could show each other whoa we wrote over it all
Hmmm why was this not part of the memory earlier
Why would you even consider
Why would you toss aside everything we had for something make-believe. I'm not tossing anything aside
We all have regrets Pia driving or a wrong or dream long past a dream land past a
Sigmund Court, we give you that second chance to make things right?
Because with our help, it's never too late
Wait these don't seem to seem like just randomly scattered memories
Could it be that the sedated sweating wearing off
You are different even from the man you were when I first met you
You're no longer aloof. You know when you're here. You're actually here
I
Know it's mesmerizing here Facebook after a pause
Shifting her gaze back up to the sky, but you've been spending so much time with me and imagining. What couldn't be?
Don't you think you're forgetting? What actually is and all that could be?
Okay look I got it. I got your message you hear me. I know you're still here. You can come and get me now
What damn it. I really thought it was her uh
Wait is that really the only way yeah?
Where did he have you been I
Figured it out Eva. I figured out the impossible I
mean I took an unholy a man of spoon it took an unholy amount of spoon feeding, but I
Guess that's what it takes when you're on the inside of it
What are you talking about?
Yes
Just what are you talking about?
The Cydia team if we're off already you don't sound too, happy about it
We're here. We're here to help Colin, and you're the mental process. That's in the way
Well lucky for you that can be a men now can't it
So looks like we're about out of time if you're going to raise me for good. You might as well hurry
No, we're not going to no we're not going to erase you
We're going to erase us
Wait what
Colin never needed our service either
He already had her
The ability to change his reality to live in a different world
One that filled the gash for what he wanted all in his head
She is what we do even
And yet she lent she left, which which could have only meant one thing
What are you trying to imply
No that can't be right
What we do is different from just this how is this different
Because there's more to it. There's more to what we do we fulfill wishes we give meaning to people's lives
We do it has to be more than just an imaginary friend
It's a lot more elaborate for sure
but for someone who had to fight just to let go of a fantasy and
embrace reality
so I can't read maybe our existence were merely an unwelcomed Hekla fire a
reminder of the maker belief the imaginary and
The endless possibility that make reality seem less than what it is
Hey you two things aren't looking good with the patient I
don't know what you're up to but you might want to get out of it and
I might wanna I mean need to
After all that huh I
Guess none of this even matters anymore
There's no way we'd still have to the time to implement any actual changes. No we might not have the 10
But what about her she?
Started linked to the machines interface, right
Without us all the procedures would be internalized so much could be done in a fraction of a moment
You'd suggest in giving sole control of the machine to a mental process of the patient
The ethical implications of that it hasn't been done for good reason
It hasn't been done because no patient hadn't had us has had a chance like this
besides
What's eternity? Just leaving mark this is errata?
But what about widow complications in the contract it says oh come on even?
When it's a contract stop tests
Guys go by I'll be right behind
Don't say you need to trust you
Are you doing this for us
Well if I were calling and on my last breath, I trust you our two strangers in white coats right
Strangers, huh?
Your colleague was right about one thing
There is more to what you do than just playing God with people's memories
You've been here for just a day yet in
All his lifetime no one has
Truly seen the world through his eyes like you have
and well your account of the first I've been able to meet -
In some silly way maybe that's a part of what Colleen really wished for it was one heck of a meet-and-greet, that's for sure
Full admin access granted to unknown root faith
You're gonna be alright just a little nervous against well given the circumstances. I'd say that's pretty high rate
Hey
Judge Keith, don't you think that in some ways I've truly existed
Well for what is where I?
Think all our memories and everything in it can be nothing, but the fiction we tells our stuff
Good luck out there Carl is counting on you I
Mean how is she any different from what they were gonna do in his head, right?
His blood pressure is dropping vital signs are fading fast. I think it's letting go
Goodbye Kali
I'm sorry for your loss. Please take all the time you need
I'll be in their living room with the paperwork when they're ready. I'll let them know I
Can't do the voices now
Dr.. Watts always a little stark isn't he?
Seeing it like this after just having been in there yeah, and it's what it is. I'm just a little cold
If it felt warm in here
Well you did back there do you think do you know if it were
hard to say I
try to dig through the data afterwards but
well
It's never been done like this before. I don't know how coherent he'll be
Guess we got another mess of a report to write
We can take care of that when the dust settles
In the meantime I just remember something
So did you succeed?
There was a complication
We try to cope with something unorthodox, but I'm not sure if we'll ever know what really happened in those nice moments
Hey Sofia said you got a lighter uh yeah
Oh of course he brought it in lemon juice
I Never stood up very tall
a live voice was fairly small
But there were times I'd wanna shout though my thoughts weren't sorted out
So I'd stumble and I'd fall
I learn to fly because of you
So if you left I could go to
And everything you saw in me
That's what I wanted to be
Did I make it after all?
Oh
Is it only greater in my mind
I'd still want it. We'll say because trading my yesterday
Is to wish my life away
As we dream men as we grow we
Have to learn to let things go
But let the wander never fade
Though we've turned ten thousand pages flying higher stop
I search for meaning, I'll instead
I finally figured that out
And all the stories inside me feels like I'm bursting at the seams
And you're here after all
All the grass on me
Is it only green my
ID still wanted the same because training my yesterday
Is to wish my life away
Oh
Looking for something old-timer
It's been a while, huh?
You haven't changed much it as far as that now
Jesus Christ
I
Got a cold...or something..
Kan, you son-of-a-bitch.. Goddammit..
Agh.
Hit me out of no-where...
Oh
My god
Oh. It's his funeral.
*Pewds Laughs*
Now where were we
Is looking sketchy at all-- Not looking sketchy at all.. I asked you to knock not hack my lock..
Switching to digital was a terrible idea.
Why don't you just keep both locks on?
Dagnabbit, Rob... I don't know why she even got you involved.
Look we don't have long. Are you guys still in or not?
You betcha!
So is this the "solution" you were talking about..?
Yeah, that's right..
*Le Gasp* What? ;o
Episode 2. "Finding Paradise".. check.. Oh!
The story continues, huh?
Oh my god, 'Thank you for being part of it.' Thank you for making it.. Goddammit.
All right... Oh--
There we go, I'm back!
Ugh... I wasn't ready for it!! :'(*Pewds laughing*
Everyone keeps writing reviews and everyone's like, "Oh, it's not as good as to the moon." or  "I didn't even cry"
I'm like, "Alright okay?"
"Well, I didn't cry really doing to the moon"
"So I doubt this will hit me" And then Jesus Christ, then the feels train just hit me..! :'(
Aghhh, I wasn't ready at all... I, uh, I don't know why.. I uhm I think..
I was less mature back then?
I know that sounds like a fucking hypocrite thing to say... It (&) with all the voices and shit I did but..
I, uh, I-I remember I enjoyed to the moon a lot,
But I don't know if I it had such an emotional impact on me, like the second one did.
And, I can only explain it for that.. But..
Holy cow I'm really glad I played this... I'm really glad I finished it.
Regardless of.. Uh..
What views were.. or whatever..
This is such an amazing experience, and I'm really glad I got to share it with you guys.
Please support this game...
Buy it on Steam!
If you enjoyed it even if you watch me play it. I think that that seems pretty fair..
And uh, yeah, I don't know.. *Chuckles in Swedish*
Thanks to Kan again, and thanks everyone for watching. I'm gonna go and...
Pretend this last 10 minutes never happened because... *Puts hand up*
Bro fist!